j'ai ramassé cher comme on dit pendant
quelques mois là j'ai pris j'ai pris la
fiction de la télé tu sais de la manière
ça s'est passé puis qu'en plus c'était
très dur parce que comme ils m'ont fait
un peu ce que font les pervers
narcissiques tu sais s'il y a comme à
passer son temps à me rabaisser il fait
qu'à la fin tu as plus confiance en toi
tu dis [ __ ] je suis une merde donc il
a fallu recommencer mais j'ai appris à
reconstruire dans ce que je mets dans le
bouquin sans rancune sans rien sans la
bienveillance c'est toujours foutu de ma
gueule oh [ __ ] c'est que de l'amour
mais ça m'a beaucoup aidé et alors j'ai
pris derrière
des deuils de genre
j'ai pris derrière des deuil
[Applaudissements]
sérieux [ __ ] j'ai pris donc on m'a par
hasard j'ai trouvé un cancer du cancer
du rein où on m'a on a opéré on fait au
moins ouvert parce que j'avais trop de
veines sur le sur les raids etc mais
c'est guéri alors ce que je voulais dire
c'est que tous les problèmes que j'ai eu
de santé ils sont guéris j'ai eu un
prédiabète j'ai une prostatite j'ai eu
le cancer et c'est et je tenais dans le
bouquet à le dire parce qu'il y a des
gens à qui on annonce aujourd'hui qu'ils
ont un cancer c'est un mot qui fait peur
tu comprends rien moi je veux leur dire
regardez je suis guéri ça se guérit ces
choses-là mais ça se guérit aussi avec
avec le mental tu sais à quel point le
moral est important dans tout ça
le mental ma vachement aidé et puis j'ai
eu la séparation avec Nana alors
justement
la séparation avec Nathalie avec qui je
suis resté plus de 30 ans avec elle mais
je suis toujours allé à côté avec moi là
vous êtes restés non mais parce que ça
aussi j'essaie d'expliquer qu'on peut
séparer sans se déchirer sans s'insulter
sans en protégeant les gamins on a une
vie sentimentale séparée mais on bosse
ensemble on est amis etc donc toutes ces
choses là c'est pour expliquer à ceux
qui passent par ces épreuves là et je
sais si j'en ai ramassé là pendant deux
ans et ben qu'on peut s'en sortir avec
un peu plus de de bienveillance de
tolérance et puis de d'optimisme
justement tu dis je fête la
Saint-Valentin avec moi-même en guise de
coeur qui bat le mien ralenti ou
s'accélère au rythme de l'effet des
antidouleurs la séparation de mon couple
c'est juxtaposée avec l'invasion du
crabe tout est arrivé en même temps tout
est arrivé en même temps mais bon c'est
la vie c'est comme ça tu sais j'ai eu
pire j'ai eu la mort de mon fils et ce
jour-là ma maman m'a dit c'est pas la
peine quelque chose c'est le début
d'autre chose et je prends tout comme ça
aujourd'hui et j'essaie de donner de
cette force que j'ai eu à tout le monde
ça fait partie de la et surtout ne pas
s'apitoyer et ne pas se plaindre je me
plains de rien
des événements de la vie c'est autre
chose qui démarre que je vis très bien
j'ai gambadé tout l'été sur les scènes
je vais en profiter au passage je veux
passer deux messages d'abord au mieux
j'ai un nouveau public c'est des mots
mais qui ont entre 15 et 22 ans qui
sautent sur mes chansons qui les
connaissent par cœur et je vais passer
aussi un message à mes copines ça j'ai
promis de le faire on dit tu diras à
Nouna que la seule musique qui vaut
c'est le métal
ah d'accord donc c'était avec des
copines du métal en ce moment mais on
les embrasse aussi bien sûr
ce bouquin aussi pour ça pour dire que
tu prends tous les gens tous les jours
tous ceux qui sont là tu prends des
trucs dans la gueule tu prends des des
maladies tu prends des des ruptures tu
prends des examens
j'ai toujours une réaction j'ai refait
ce que j'avais fait la première fois la
première personne que j'ai croisé j'ai
dit [ __ ] on vient de m'annoncer un
truc c'est un signe astrologique je sais
plus lequel Capricorne scorpion ah non
cancer c'est ça quand même me dire parce
que un petit peu du monde c'est pas de
mal j'ai pris ça comme une maladie
comment il faut savoir aujourd'hui que
ça se guérit aussi voilà quand tu l'as
appris tu dis parce que c'est arrivé en
une période comme tu le dis Patrick
c'est vrai que moi je te dis tout moi
c'est vrai que à un moment voilà je sais
que je savais plutôt de tes nouvelles on
m'avait dit ouais pour l'instant Patrick
faut le laisser un peu voilà mais il y a
tout qui et puis tu te bats quoi et puis
je te dis j'ai connu des des trucs
tellement plus violents cancer c'est un
cancer c'est la vie quoi je veux dire
c'est c'est ça arrive ça arrive à plein
de gens là je suis du bol j'appelle ça
un chancaire d'ailleurs parce qu'on me
l'a trouvé par hasard j'ai commencé bah
j'ai fait une écho de contrôle pour rien
et puis j'ai un toubib formidable qui
qui m'a qui m'a dit à une tâche blanche
là tu devrais faire une IRM tu me fais
pas chier je suis claustro et puis il a
insisté fait une biopsie et ça donne la
phrase la plus surréaliste comme toubib
dit à son patient quand je dis que c'est
un cancer il m'a dit ben je suis bien
content je suis bien content oui je suis
bien content de t'avoir poussé à faire
des investigations donc n'hésitez pas
allez vous faire contrôler parce que
c'était une tumeur non invasive ça m'est
instable il suffit d'enlever si on le
sait assez tôt
il faut juste dire aux gens faites-vous
contrôler allez regarder et donc ce truc
là on l'a enlevé bon ils m'ont fait j'ai
une cicatrice de 30 cm sur le bide mais
ça m'a pas empêché de cavaler tout l'été
sur les scènes c'est difficile mais si
on s'apitoie sur soi-même si on se
plaint on est mort donc il faut pas
s'apitoyer il faut partir moi je suis
reparti dans plein de projet ta
séparation avec Nana qu'on appelle parce
que on l'adore moi aussi je l'adore
ta Passi 30 ans avec elle qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé parce que tu en parles dans
le livre c'est pour ça que je me permets
d'en parler elle a eu besoin un peu
d'une liberté différente et ce que je
peux comprendre et est-ce que c'est
possible l'amour l'amour pour moi c'est
accepter que l'autre soit heureux même
en dehors de soi donc si elle est plus
heureuse en dehors de moi ce qui est pas
forcément le cas on est on veut il y a
pas de quoi se fâcher si tu aimes les
gens si tu tiens à eux et ben tu
t'arranges pour qu'il soit heureux
manquer quelque chose c'est peut-être
moi qui est pas su lui apporter s'il
manquait quelque chose elle a peut-être
trouvé ailleurs je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas ça ne gâche en rien d'abord les
30 années qu'on a passé ensemble et je
te dis notre amitié elle est en coulisse
avec moi elle est ici aussi je sais et
Patrick là c'est
tout ce qui est arrivé après tu dis
voilà le premier truc qui m'est arrivé
c'est c'est évident de la télévision
c'est vrai que voilà tu es violent ça a
été violent c'est est-ce que tu penses
que c'est c'est ça aussi qui a fait
qu'après tu as eu tu sais tu as changé
avec tous les trucs comme ça sont liés à
des problèmes de santé le stress ça crée
ça c'est les contrariétés moi je sais
qu'après le mélanome que j'avais eu
c'était après la mort de ma mère donc
c'est quelque chose auquel je
m'attendais je m'entendais à avoir un
truc physique tu t'es dit ça va je
croise les doigts je m'en fous bien sûr
tu l'avais dit à tes proches tu l'avais
dit que je sens que tu vas avoir un truc
parce que ça va trop affecté tu le sens
forcément quand regarde tous les gens
qui ont eu des deuils de proches il se
déclenche des trucs derrière forcément
obligatoirement ça va avec le mental
encore une fois et le stress sont plus
importants mais encore une fois si tu te
plains et si tu tapis toi et si tu te
dis tu vois tu en veux au sort tu dises
pas normal etc tu t'en sors pas c'est
comme ça alors il y a il y a un passage
très fort dans le livre où tu dis je ne
te cache pas qu'il est temps le 9 mm là
tout près dans le tiroir de l'armoire
d'en face [ __ ] comme souvent j'en ai
envie il suffirait d'un élan éboum sans
peur et sans regret lasser de tout alors
boum une balle dans la tête pour
accoster de mon plein gré avant le
naufrage j'ai pas les couilles pas pour
l'instant tout simplement parce que je
n'en ai pas les couilles pardon pour la
grossièreté mais j'écris des mots comme
ils viennent le suicide est un acte de
courage pas une lâcheté ouais parce que
en fait j'ai toujours été comme ça ça y
est je me suis toujours dit j'ai pas
choisi le moment où j'arrivais
j'aimerais bien choisir le moment où je
pars mais pas je me je veux pas j'ai pas
envie de me flinguer de désespoir c'est
pas ça c'est que j'ai eu un bol énorme
malgré les les douleurs sur j'ai eu j'ai
eu une chance énorme de vivre une vie
fascinante extraordinaire alors une
métaphore dans le bouquin je dis j'ai
bouffé j'ai une vie où j'ai bouffé du
caviar du champagne je veux pas finir
avec une madeleine pourrie une compote
pourrie quoi moi j'ai vu ma mère ce
traitait d'hôpitaux en hôpitaux pendant
4 ans je veux pas ça moi si je peux
m'arrêter avant pourquoi tu as pensé à
me suicider
scène que je suis vivant parce que là je
suis vraiment vivant j'ai des projets
partout tout va bien mais la déchéance
physique et mentale surtout c'est un
truc que j'aurais vachement de mal
accepté ouais ouais ça serait un truc
que j'aurais vachement de mal accepté
mais faudrait pas être triste pour moi
parce que ça serait quelque chose que
j'ai voulu que j'ai non sera triste je
te le dis mais le plus tard
j'ai pas envie mais c'est vrai
que tu as pensé à ça j'ai toujours pensé
à ça toujours je suis toujours moi c'est
un truc que j'ai toujours moi la vie la
mort m'ont toujours passionné c'est
c'est un chemin qui est qui est
merveilleux la mort c'est fabuleux c'est
le seul moment où on est tous égaux tous
qui conçoit quel que soit notre fortune
quel que soit notre beau toilettes je la
souhaite pas aux toilettes aussi on est
toujours à ça
évidemment que je souhaite pas elle
viendra parce que c'est lucide aussi tu
dis j'ai 68 balais tu regardes autour de
toi des mecs qui tombent chez des
copains qui sont tombés à 66 67
peut-être que je vais vivre je vais
revenir dans 20 ans ici tu seras vieux
tu feras encore ton émission ils sont
tous là pas tous
et puis il y en a qui sont plus là on
essaie de qui on veut parler voilà mais
bon
voilà une chose importante dans le
bouquin c'est ma manière de penser c'est
que tout est écrit pour moi moi je fais
partie des gens qui pensent que tout est
écrit qu'on a un karma et sur c'est pas
la peine de lutter contre l'inéluctable
puisque ça doit arriver tu vois
benjaminer
la rencontre avec Jeff elle devait
arriver alors on s'est rencontré par
hasard c'était un hasard le jour où je
viens le voir je peux être complètement
ailleurs ça a été un déclencheur je
pense que les choses doivent arriver
sont alors quand on pense comme ça on se
met moins en colère contre les contre
les coups du sort on se dit mais voilà
ça devait arriver c'est là maintenant
essayons de gérer et je maintiens encore
une fois quitte à passer pour un
bisounours que quand tu restes dans la
bienveillance quand tu restes dans le
regard vers les autres quand tu rentres
dans la générosité et ben tu t'en sors
mieux que les hommes Gilbert ils s'en
sortent très bien tu évoques également
l'argent à la télé mais tu rapportes ça
la prostitution tu dis que ce n'est pas
un sujet tabou pour toi je n'ai aucun
état d'âme par rapport aux somme que m'a
rapporté la télévision c'est le salaire
justifier de toute prostitution bah oui
plus de luxe chacun sur son bout de
trottoir on met en valeur nos avantages
on agit son racoles et plus le client
est content et puis il paye c'est
incroyable
c'est vrai que c'est un peu ça tu
considères les animateur comme des
prostituées de luxe hein tu considères
des animateurs comme des prostituées de
luxe
on vend notre cam quoi
on essaie de séduire et puis si le
client est content ben on continue voilà
mais c'est vrai que c'est une chanson à
l'époque qui s'appelait garçon de joie
alors et tu as des nouvelles de leur nom
[Applaudissements]
tu dis que les programmes sont devenus
un petit peu cheap à la télé et tu me
cite dans ce passage tu dis les
programmes ça me nuisent au profit des
publicités de plus en plus envahissants
pour certains c'est transparents mon
pote Hanouna assume le même décor pour
une multitude d'émissions et
chroniqueurs à la pige ordinaire
ils ne rate pas l'occasion d'en
plaisanter en étant niant chez eux toute
velléité d'augmentation voilà ça c'est
vrai pas d'arnaque un sous c'est un sou
il le dit lui-même c'est que de la télé
et cette télé là est faite pour d'abord
faire du profit il a au moins le netteté
de le reconnaître c'est aussi pour cela
que j'estime merci Patrick cyril est un
clown un bateleur de génie un léger la
pas du gain va avec la panoplie bien sûr
et tu finis et tu finis mais vu la somme
de travail et les résultats les
bénéfices sont mérités et j'en profite
pour faire un parallèle avec ceux qui
font des leçons de morale et et qui sont
là aussi pour le fric et c'est ça voilà
c'est lucide sur ça parce que c'est la
c'est la course au buzz même sur les
chaînes d'info
là depuis que j'ai sorti le bouquet ils
essaient de me faire du buzz avec tout
je sais que c'est la règle des choses
mais ça m'amuse ça m'amuse moi ce qui
m'intéresse surtout dans ce livre je te
dis encore une fois c'est d'abord c'est
un exutoire pour moi parce que écrire
c'est formidable je le conseille à tout
le monde même si c'est pas lu et puis ça
va me permettre d'aider certaines
personnes j'ai tout c'est pas altruiste
c'est c'est qu'on est dans les autres je
me fais du bien à moi alors tu t'es tu
te fais du bien aussi parce que tu
parles de sexe dans le livre un sujet
non pas encore j'espère sur le dans le
tome 2 un sujet tabou mais pas pour toi
qui décide qu'ils décident de te confier
de dévoiler de nombreux détails tu
assumes ton libertin dans le livre tu
racontes quelques détails et ce côté de
ta personne ne plaît pas tout le monde
dans ton entourage tu dis j'ai toujours
fait ce que j'ai voulu de mon sexe et de
mes solitudes j'aime et autant les
enamourir romantiques que les traversées
du bois de Boulogne exactement c'est
incroyable ça quoi tu as déjà et tu es
au bois de Boulogne bien sûr
j'ai incroyable tu sais comment ça se
passe chez moi
[Applaudissements]
c'est dans le livre de Patrick hein
chaque jour
moi je suis pas un pervers ma vie
sexuelle s'arrête au consentement de
l'autre bien sûr j'ai jamais violé
personne c'est pas mon truc je regarde
pas les films porno un stream tease ça
me laisse complètement froid mais c'est
vrai que je suis en amoureux de la
liberté et dans le milieu libertin c'est
pas que du cul c'est une façon d'être et
dans le milieu dans ce milieu là qui est
libre et ben il y a pas de riche il y a
pas de pauvres il y a pas de moche il y
a pas de beau il y a du respect et s'il
y a pas de respect ça n'existe pas donc
c'est un monde qui me plaît voilà alors
après j'ai aucun mais tu as déjà assis
avec ça Patrick c'est vrai que c'est fou
ce que tu dis parce que alors là il y a
un souci avec la morale seulement la
morale c'est l'ennemi du moral mais tu
as déjà été tu faisais quoi avec les
travestis du mois de septembre
la première chose que je leur demandais
c'est quel est le dernier animateur qui
est passé vous voir
Hanouna est passé
chez moi
mais ah ouais non mais c'est fou de dire
ça dans un livre Patrick parce que si je
suis un infidèle chronique et un
libertin assumé je n'ai aucune barrière
si ce n'est celle du consentement comme
ça je m'interdis tout comportement qui
pourrait dévaluer mes partenaires
multiples mais j'ai toujours été un
collectionneur invétéré et si j'en ai la
possibilité je ne laisserai passer
aucune occasion si furtif soit-elle sans
aucun a priori d'âge ou de beauté
[Rires]
absolument dans les dans les relations
que j'ai eu à ce que mon regard d'après
soit le même que celui d'avance qui est
pas le cas de tout le monde mais j'ai de
l'estime pour toutes celles que
j'appelle des passants que j'aime
énormément
moi il y a un truc qui me gêne dans
l'amour traditionnel c'est la
possessivité voilà j'estime que
j'appartiens à personne et que personne
ne m'appartient et c'est en ça c'est
très féministe parce que je te dis
encore une fois ce que j'aime dans mes
relations c'est que l'autre soit heureux
même en dehors de moi
elle le savait ton ta femme comment elle
le savait ta femme passe
évidemment qu'elle savait des choses et
puis elle est elle en a d'autant plus de
de mairie c'était un deal il y a eu un
deal entre nous
il y a surtout un deal de respect mutuel
dans le fond parce que j'ai jamais
triché sur ce que j'étais il y a
tellement de mecs qui promettent à leur
femme d'être des modèles et qui ne s'y
tiennent tu dis ça pour castagner
en plus je n'ai jamais demandé une
je suis pas du genre à dire moi je fais
ce que je veux à la maison tu vois c'est
c'est voilà c'est ce qui s'appelle un
couple moderne avec un respect mutuel
avec beaucoup d'admiration parce que
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration je crois que
c'est marié quatre fois je me suis
planté un peu quatre fois mais c'est
parce que je suis pas fait pour ça quoi
tu dis je suis bien trop libertaire
ouais la liberté pour moi est quelque
chose essentiel et c'est vrai que dans
ce livre j'en dévoile un petit peu plus
que d'habitude je dévoile pas tout non
plus mais c'est pareil c'est pour
essayer d'aider des gens qui tu sais les
il y a des crimes passionnelles tous les
jours quand je vois les gens se
déchiraient sur tu en as tous les jours
des buzz comme ça sur la gueule se tape
dessus à la moindre séparation on
l'écrit tu dis j'ai pas envie de vivre
ça tu dis tu dis tu es libertin mais pas
échangiste
non c'est pas c'est pas la même chose
[Rires]
les libertins
Molière champ de la fontaine
et en plus si tu remarques bien dans
leur œuvre c'est des gens qui avaient
une acidité par rapport à la société il
se trouve que j'ai aussi ce truc là ça
va avec mais tu vas dans des clubs et
tout
ça
c'est un ami c'est un ami m'appelle
jamais pour sortir avec lui Patrick
c'est pas aussi réducteur que c'est pas
aussi réducteur que ce que tu dis j'ai
beaucoup d'amis avec on peut passer des
soirées à discuter mais on discute santé
à poils
et l'échangisme l'échangisme c'est du
troc c'est ça
c'est tout simple le libertinage c'est
une manière d'aborder la vie et la
sexualité d'une manière avec élégance
c'est la définition du dictionnaire avec
[Applaudissements]
des couples qui s'échangent c'est du
troc moi
mes compagnes je les ai jamais amené
dans des endroits comme ça je suis
toujours allé en célibataire parce que
tous mélangent parce que en plus c'est
le c'est le tarmac pour les c'est le
serrage pour les chevaliers du yel parce
que c'est il y a tout le tout le côté
LGBT qui représenté chacun est libre de
faire ce qu'il veut voilà je dis attends
je prends pas pour ça je dis pas fait de
ça mais le livre le livre de Patrick est
formidable parce que
en fait comme moi je suis comme ça je
n'en ai pas honte parce que je ne fais
rien pourquoi non il respectueux
exactement moi tout le reste c'est moi
je sais mais il y a pas de harcèlement
chez les libertins il y a pas de viol il
y a pas de manque de respect parce que
le premier manque de respect c'est
dehors tu fais plus partie de la troupe
donc c'est un monde qui me va plutôt
bien voilà et quand mais je pense pas
que ça je te rassure je sais mon Patrick
parce que tu me connais voilà c'est ça
ça m'a intéressé aussi c'est normal
les mecs ou pas
[Applaudissements]
raconter des parts de ton intuition s'il
te plaît non mais bye parce que je suis
sûr que tous les spectateurs c'est
Patrick tu imagines moi j'habite à côté
du livre c'est pas du tout mais non non
il y a vraiment énormément de choses
dans le livre comme je vous l'ai dit
alors il y a un truc aussi fond du livre
c'est ça c'est que il faut rester vivant
tout ça même ces histoires de de sexe et
cetera donc je suis pas je suis pas un
obsédé non plus ça fait partie de la vie
c'est vivre c'est comme manger c'est
comme tout ça ça fait partie de la vie
voilà et moi je préfère tu sais je cite
je cite plus tard au début de du livre
qui disait il faut pas il faut pas
naître pour exister il faut naître pour
vivre car moi je préfère vivre voilà
alors t'évoque dans ton livre aussi des
questions que tu te poses sur le vaccin
tes analyses ne présentaient aucun
efforts alors c'est ça alors dans le tu
dis et le vaccin dans tout ça d'accord
j'ai 68 ans d'accord pour la conséquence
des excès en tout genre d'accord pour le
retour de bâton des contrariétés ce que
tu nous disais tout à l'heure mais je
constate avant le vaccin anticoïde
j'avais des années nickel et aucune
pathologie sérieuse à l'horizon et un
mois après les injections début de
diabète prostatique et pour finir cancer
du rein alors ça ça a été repris partout
je vais t'expliquer partout parce que
une fois pour toute ce que tout le temps
une bonne fois pour toute moi je me suis
fait vacciner déjà une chose quand j'ai
des trucs de santé je vais pas sur les
réseaux sociaux je vais voir un docteur
un toubib moi tout ce que je lis sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est bien mais moi je
fais confiance à mes docteurs et je les
remercie d'ailleurs parce que c'est eux
qui m'ont diagnostiqué le cancer et
c'est eux qui me l'ont guéri et qui
m'ont guéri tout le reste et mon père
est docteur il se trouve qu'à un moment
quand il y a eu le covid mais to bibi
m'ont dit il vaut mieux que tu te fasses
vacciner parce que ça peut t'éviter des
formes graves donc j'ai écouté mais tout
de suite et j'ai même dit aux gens
faites-vous vacciner pour ce que j'ai vu
des gens mourir à côté de moi qui ne se
sont pas fait vacciner j'ai vu aussi des
gens qui n'étaient pas vaccinés qui ont
jamais rien chopé
j'affirme rien simplement comme le début
du diabète la prostatique qui sont
finies maintenant on démarre un mois
après je me suis posé des questions j'ai
eu un doute c'est ça et le doute j'en ai
parlé très longuement il y a quelques
jours avec Raphaël Enthoven que j'aime
beaucoup avec moi
je l'adore parce qu'il m'a reproché ça
en disant à partir du moment c'est pas
un doute c'est un soupçon et le soupçon
n'est pas le doute en fait tu vois on
est parti dans des trucs philosophiques
ce que je veux dire simplement parce
qu'il y a une nana qui m'a allumé ce
matin sur RTL il faut qu'elle se
renseigne non plus elle a dit urbation
diabète c'est parce qu'il picole j'ai
arrêté de picoler il y a 40 ans il faut
se renseigner avant de me dire comme
Castaldi déjà 40 minutes
non je me dis que peut-être ce que j'ai
eu
c'était l'attent peut-être que c'est
arrivé normalement il y a tous mes
toubibs m'ont dit c'est du hasard et
puis en même temps que tu peux pas
t'empêcher de te poser la question je me
je n'affirmerai il y a un truc il y a un
seul truc qui me gêne dans l'histoire
c'est que tu sais quand tu achètes un
médicament il y a une notice avec des
effets indésirables il y en a bien sûr
trois pages faut dire tout qui est là
pour le vaccin quand tu quand tu te
poses la question il y a personne qui te
dit
il peut y avoir des effets secondaires
apparemment il y a aucun aucun effet
secondaire tu as traité de complotiste
après je m'en fous l'adjectif on peut me
traiter ce qu'on veut l'autre jour j'ai
dit je suis pas complotiste mais il me
semble rentrer dedans parce que j'ai dit
ça honnêtement je sais pas pose des
questions en termes de religion moi je
suis agnostique par exemple Dieu je sais
pas donc il y a les athées il y a les
croyants moi je doute et ben je dis
simplement que je doute ça veut pas dire
que j'accuse je n'aime pas les intégrer
des deux côtés tu vois les gens qui te
disent oui le vaccin est responsable
tout ou ceux qui disent non le vaccin
est responsable de rien j'en doute c'est
tout je partage ce doute je suis pas le
seul non parce qu'il y a plein de gens
autour de moi qui ont eu des pathologies
qui se disent je pense que c'est moi
j'attends qu'il y a un toubib qui
viennent me prouver parce que la preuve
c'est pas moi la portée c'est à eux je
veux des Tobi viennent nous voir il me
dit je vous promets qu'il n'y a aucun
effet secondaire avec ce vaccin et ce
jour-là quand on me prouvera qu'un aura
aucun peut-être que tu dis c'est Patrick
c'est ça tu l'as expliqué on a aussi ce
matin au téléphone il le dit c'est vrai
que dans chaque médicament il y a un
truc à la fin il fait secondaire la
porte lequel même un médicament même une
pastille là non mais je te le dis non
mais c'est vrai il te dit c'est pas ni
Balda ouais tu as toujours ce qui serait
logique même si c'est pas grave la
chimio on sait très bien que la chimio
ça entraîne des des effets secondaires
pourquoi ce vaccin en entraînerait pas
c'est tout mais on ce qui le défendent
disent non il y en a pas
je suis un peu coincé
j'ai le doute voilà je vous écoute très
attentivement moi je vous trouve très
mesuré et très les pieds sur terre la
mesure dans ce domaine là parce qu'on a
personne à la sûreté personne n'a la
vérité en tout cas non ça je suis
d'accord avec vous après moi je suis pas
médecin donc je suis pas moi non plus
c'est ça le problème
tout le monde se découvert médecin qui
peut se poser des tendances à faire
confiance au toubib mais moi je
comprends qu'on pose des questions bien
sûr quand il dit je dirais que Patrick
je te dis quand tu me l'a dit ce matin
je me suis dit c'est vrai qu'il a raison
il y a toujours un truc voilà il le dit
la notice la notice il y a des effets
secondaires moi j'ai l'impression que
c'est un vaccin où il y a des milliards
de gens qui ont été vaccinés il y a une
femme vigilance qui n'a jamais été comme
ça sur aucun vaccin et j'ai l'impression
que au contraire on n'a jamais autant
surveillé un vaccin il y a jamais eu
autant de remontées sur le vaccin des
effets secondaires justement comme
jamais ce qui est plutôt moi je trouve
rassurant pour le coup après
je l'ai fait en faisant confiance comme
beaucoup de gens et j'ai pas eu bon
après moi si ça doit vous rassurer de
penser que c'est le vaccin qui fait que
je cherche pas à me rassurer je me pose
juste la question comme je me pose la
question sur dieu s'il existe aussi il
existe pas ça n'engage que ma pensée à
moi d'ailleurs vous l'avez très bien
exposé après ce qui m'énerve un peu
c'est le fanatisme les deux côtés moi
j'ai plein de copines à moi de copains
qui sont pas fait vacciner mais bien sûr
il reste des amis pour ça et puis j'en
ai plein d'autres qui me disent ah oui
mais on a eu ça derrière ça ça alors
est-ce que c'est le hasard est-ce que
c'est quelque chose de l'attent que ça a
déclenché ou est-ce que ça y est je ne
sais pas moi ça me rend dingue contexte
de fou de complotiste toute personne qui
remet en cause l'efficacité ou la
fiabilité du vaccin il y a énormément de
personnes qui ont eu des effets
secondaires il y a de plus en plus de
personnalités il y a des vidéos qui
ressortent notamment Nathalie Marquay
qui disait que Jean-Pierre Pernaut ait
fait 4 mini AVC après cette vacciné il y
a deux personnes moi du tout que les
effets secondaires viennent de là
il y a plein de gens qui le pensent
regardez il y avait aussi Justin Bieber
qui s'est retrouvé bien sûr avec une
partie du visage paralysée peut-être à
cause du vaccin et c'est bien pourquoi
il était là avant tu vois d'accord par
contre le reste j'ai des copains toubibs
qui me disent ça n'a aucun rapport on te
le promet et d'autres qui me disent
peut-être donc je peux pas avoir un
jugement définitif je peux pas manger de
votre diabète
du diabète que j'ai eu et je suis guéri
du cancer donc tout va bien vous allez
toujours au bois de Boulogne
[Rires]
ça prouve que je suis en bonne santé
en bonne santé
avec le président de la République
je t'explique non c'est pas que c'est
pas ça moi mes relations mes relations
avec le président qui sont on s'est vu
deux fois dans notre vie j'ai des
relations par SMS pour l'alerter sur des
choses j'ai toujours fait ça vous
demandez gilets jaunes aujourd'hui je
l'alerte sur le fait que le plus grand
problème des gens c'est qu'ils arrivent
pas à remplir le caddie c'est ça là qui
m'écoute ou qui m'écoutent pas c'est pas
mon problème c'est le sien il a plein de
gens comme ça il a une centaine de
personnes au moins à qui demande un avis
c'est que comme moi j'ai eu ce truc là
je me suis permise au lieu de venir sur
un plateau dégueulé en disant ouais ça
ça j'ai dit voilà ce qui m'arrive
qu'est-ce que tu en penses et il m'a
répondu pour moi ça n'a aucun rapport
sa réponse j'ai mis le SMS que j'ai ça
n'a aucun rapport mais j'entends ce que
tu me dis et j'ai dit moi j'ai pas trop
envie de faire le quatrième je vais même
dire à l'époque le passe vaccinal je
trouve ça inutile il m'a dit pas moi
donc tu vois c'est des c'est pas je
demande pas des faveurs pour moi je vais
pas chercher des trucs j'essaie
d'alerter de dire un truc il en pense
qu'il en veut mais mon boulot comme j'ai
la chance de pouvoir communiquer c'est
de transmettre ce que j'entends en bas
pour que ça remonte jusqu'en haut après
ce qu'ils en veulent voilà ça s'arrête à
ça simplement si j'ai des puisque j'ai
les moyens de le faire combien de
personnes aimeraient pouvoir dire
monsieur le Président voilà ce qui va
pas j'aimerais vous en tenir informé
après la déesse m'appartient pas c'est
un passage formidable aussi ça dans le
livre de Patrick fief et Jean-Marc on
écoute
de temps en temps tu as dû lui remonter
des trucs je crois que c'est notre rôle
plutôt que d'aller publiquement gueuler
c'est notre aussi